[Music]
welcome to GPU infrastructure for
compute workloads like HPC and ml my
name is Chris Klieman I'm the product
manager of GPUs on GCE and I play video
games who here in their life has played
a video game sometime
now or in the past almost everybody well
thank you thank you because you're
helping innovation the question is why
why does playing video games help with
innovation let's talk about that
according to ml researchers the majority
of them saying access to compute power
is a major roadblock to success major
roadblock to success of innovation to
come doing competitive things in the
industry
it's just access to compute so as
researchers as scientists as
infrastructure engineers as businesses
we need access to compute and how does
gaming come into play a long long time
ago there were no such things GPUs games
were played on our CPU but then graphics
got better and better so companies came
out with hardware specific to drawing
little triangles and playing video games
and make them more realistic and thanks
to all of you who played video games
those GPU companies were successful
right every person in college would
probably have a GPU in their computer
access was everywhere and because of
that access people thought what can I do
with this hardware well it turns out
it's not just for drawing triangles
right it also is about doing math and
compute so Nvidia as well as other
Hardware accelerating companies said
let's take a partion of this code a
portion that's all about math and
offload it to hardware processing all
right so that's what GPU computers about
majority the code still runs on CPU but
something that takes a long long time
that's put it over to a dedicated
hardware accelerator pretty
straightforward but it
really really helpful and it's thank of
thanks to you for playing games that's
made it all happened so use cases for
GPUs here are the common ones right
machine learning training and inference
HPC right H we see there's lots of
different types of workloads that fall
into that and visualization and all of
these are about getting access to fast
cheaper compute to drive innovation so
let's look at those use cases a little
more first training training on GPUs is
all about the creation of the AI right
maybe it's about data center cooling or
efficiency it's about creating that
logic maybe it's about self-driving cars
but the training is the aspect of how do
i do something an automated way and how
do I do it I don't have to program the
logic machine learning inference is the
opposite once you have that artificial
intelligence it's doing something with
it in the Google Translate application
for example it's how to take one
language and make it into the other
right for production systems like
self-driving cars does it happen
continuously right or maybe for reports
it's a batch workload but either way
it's about doing something with your AI
HPC one of our customers is slumber
slumber J and what they do is they have
a whole bunch of data right from these
sonar systems where they put sound down
to the ground get data back and now they
have to calculate where are these
natural resources so they do that number
crunching out of thousands of GPUs on
Google Cloud but not only that then they
do about visualization where they used
those GPUs to do a graphic application
to show engineers in the energy industry
right how to get access and see that and
do visualization on visualization
there's really three parts right remote
desktops that's what I was just talking
about HPC workloads
AutoCAD doing some sort of real-time
view of complex data right again gaming
in the cloud on GPUs is workload and
also movie rendering right a lot of
these software that run
on GPUs for rendering is supported in
the cloud obviously so that's the high
level right that's what GPUs are that's
what GPU computing is those are the
workloads that run on it now the rest of
this talk is going to be talking about
the problems with GPU compute right or
the challenges or how'd it get started
right getting started could be hard what
hardware you're gonna use what software
you're gonna use how do you scale how do
you optimize performance
how do you do DevOps or manage large
clusters of infrastructure and again
going back to that innovation problem
how do you solve the access problem how
do you you yourself get access or your
organization or your college so let's
look at GPUs on Google clapping our
customers trust us there's a lot of
customers across HPC and mo workloads
using GPUs for their processing on
Google cloud right open ai a leading AI
research organization social media
companies energy companies self-driving
car companies right all using GPU
compute right second we're really really
happy to partner with Nvidia right the
Google Nvidia partnership is really what
makes it accessible they're creating
great accelerators that our customers
using for compute but not only that the
software they're working on right the
partnership to the software available in
the cloud marketplace or the open source
integrations between the two companies
and for our large GPU customers it's not
often they're it's not rare that Google
and Nvidia both engage with a customer
and help them get started so Google
Cloud GPUs our software stack and our
future stacks different than other
clouds and I'll just give you a
highlight of them first performance it's
all about obviously you're adopting a
GPU from compute because you're trying
to get access to more compute and better
performance so we have PCI pass-through
mode right it's bare metal performance
on the virtual machine if you're running
big workloads with multiple GPUs or v100
GPU has n V link right where the speed
between GPUs doesn't have to go through
the CPU or the
PCI bus and it's a high-bandwidth second
are broad offering of GPUs we have five
different models right from the older K
80s to the brand-new T fours and because
we have five models you could pick and
choose the right price performance and
feature set for your specific workload
also flexibility we have custom VM
shapes right it's not where you're going
to pick the infrastructure set for your
workload that is just what's available
right it's you pick the amount of CPU
memory what kind of storage what type of
GPU how many GPUs and because of that
it's helping you with access you don't
have to pay for a bunch of
infrastructure here you don't need for
your training inference HPC workload
right only pay for what you need
save a bunch of money we offer a bunch
of things how to help you save money
with automatic discounts or preemptable
vm's that we'll talk about we make it
really easy to get started
whatever code you have that you need to
run on a GPU you can get started in a
matter of seconds and if you are disk
i/o bound we have local SSD is an option
or you could attach it to your VM or
remove it to your V from your VM only
pay for it if you need that fast disk
i/o so here are five GPUs that we offer
okay it's kind of a hodge podge slide
here but what you'll see it's just
flexibility five different GPUs a bunch
of different performance characteristics
the ability to pick any number of GPU
that you want CPU and memory just it
talks about our broad offering but it's
not just the hardware right it's about
the software work right and vidi has
done a great job by again going back in
time all these GPUs for gaming they
launched the CUDA what development
library that CUDA development library
takes all of these GPUs it makes a
common framework to interface so no
matter what programming language you're
using C or Python or whatever you're
just going into that CUDA programming
language and as new models of GPUs come
out you don't have to worry about
changing your code right you're just
using CUDA but it doesn't stop at CUDA
right there's specific libraries for
based on the kind of math you want to do
right there's machine learning libraries
like CU DNN for deep learning network
right or COO boss or open ACC right
these pieces make it so that you don't
have to worry about low-level math and
you're just using that the software
framework to do your computations and
then going up a level sometimes you
don't want to worry about CUDA
programming if you're doing machine
learning you might be using PI torch MX
net tensorflow right more you more
user-friendly customer friendly code
right and because of Nvidia is built a
software stack there's tons of
applications that are built on top of
this so no matter where you're running
your application whether it be arm Prem
around the cloud right you're gonna feel
comfortable that you'll be able to run
in GPUs in the cloud hybrid model
wherever you want over time but there's
a lot here there's a lot of software
like to get started you have to worry
about what GPU my I don't get how do i
download this the software how do I get
started
so Glu cloud offers what we call the
deep learning VM image the deep learning
VM image works for both HPC and ml and
includes all the software you need to
get started it has the drivers
prepackaged we do performance
optimizations like nickel 2 built in so
you don't have to worry about network or
multi GPU performance optimizations it
has a lot of the ML frameworks
pre-installed like MX net or tensorflow
it even has notebook as a service
built-in so all you got to do is create
a VM pick this image and it has all that
great software that is in the open
source as well as provided by Nvidia so
this will look a little bit more about
one of our latest two GPUs the v100 from
Nvidia with eight of these in a single
vent VM can get up to a petaflop of
performance right this is great for HPC
and ml workloads again up to six hundred
and twenty-two gigabytes of memory 96 B
CPUs and if you're running multiple of
them we have the special Envy link
connections between them right this is
really really good if you want to have
larger ML models right or if you're
trying to get the time for ML training
to go really down to innovate faster
this is typically your scale-up model
you want the most powerful GPU right
this is the one to go
so looking a little bit about one of our
customers open AI
again it's funny how gaming comes into
play here but opening a is using gaming
to innovate in ml they do something
called reinforcement learning and what
that is is they play a bunch of games
over and over and over again and they
use a technique where they're using
Google Cloud play a thousands of games
take the results of those games put it
into an ml training pipeline and create
better Artefill of artificial
intelligence they use that logic to
submit AI on the dota2 video game where
they compete against the world's best
players they really like our platform
not only for this scale right hundreds
of thousands of CPUs thousands of GPUs
not just the scale not just the price
but our support they love coming to us
and talking to us about we're trying to
do this AI think how do we do it
we're having problems with performance
right how do we resolve these
bottlenecks we're really proud that they
picked Google cloud so one of the next
GPUs that we just launched the NVIDIA
Turing T 4 we just announced this week
that were GA and the product we're the
first major cloud to offer it this this
GPU is really about scale out workloads
both ml training and they'll inference
HPC visualization right it's only a 70
watt 75 watt card so what that means is
you're gonna it's not about scaling up
in the terms of I have one workload if
one VM I want a large workload I want to
be able to replicate that out and scale
by going horizontal it has a bunch of
unique features that we'll dig into
first is the new types of technology
into the chip right compared to Pascal
versus Turing they've added two things
one the same tensor cores that are in V
104 mix precision training right are
also entering but they've got they've
gone further right and made it more
flexible and the second change in the
hardware's RT course which are great for
real-time ray tracing support for
visualization so great innovation by
Nvidia based on that RT cars in real
time ray tracing we've partnered with
Nvidia to bring quadro virtual
workstations to Google Cloud in the
marketplace
right that is once you tie in your mln
HBC workload perhaps and you want a
visualization component creative vm i
turn on real-time ray tracing for
optimal performance and 3d rendering
right and be able to show your results
why is multi precision helpful and are
about access to compute so this is an
illustration about the tensor course
right and since GPU compute it's all
about offloading math for the first time
ever in a new way the T for GPU offers
the ability to choose the amount of
performance you want with choosing the
level of precision you want so for HPC
workloads right you might want as high
precision as possible but maybe for ML
inference it turns out you can lower
precision down 2 into 8 or maybe even in
4 right and it doesn't change your
models accuracy with predictions but you
get a bunch more performance so for the
first time ever write in CUDA or in
tensor flow or in your ml frameworks you
could choose which level of performance
you want and trade off based on accuracy
so that trade-offs like it's great you
get great performance great pricing then
bit cost of that you could do more
innovation by just doing ml and HPC over
and over again to innovate but maybe
it's hard to do that maybe it's your
researchers your developers or engineers
maybe they're focusing on customer
features over that optimization
performance so Nvidia just announced
something called a + PM automatic mix
precision where in some ml frameworks
like MX nan and tensorflow you don't
have to do that optimization yourself
just add two lines of code right and
NVIDIA goes and it automatically
optimizes your model so our T for
offering that we just did a ga
announcement of this week available in 8
regions right pricing is incredibly
attractive 95 cents an hour but as low
as twenty-nine cents an hour for
preemptable VMs so let's look at ml
inference a little bit right and on this
T for GPU so y ml inference on the t4
first that mix precision right looking
at the performance of the various
generations of GPUs
you'll see that the amount of teraflops
percent flops per second increases
dramatically for the next generation T
for GPU and depending on right what
level of performance you're getting
right you're gonna pick that precision
that matters second latency right with
CPU in France Layton sees measures in
the tens of milliseconds right but low
latency is really important for
real-time inference workloads right when
your end users using the application you
want that so t4 is purposely built for
this right let's look at some sat at Sun
and user workloads right well no matter
what your model is you're gonna see
speed ups right with video inference
language image shop image recognition
you know 5 X 3 X speed improvements
right over the previous GPUs and if
you're comparing four CPUs it's even
more so we talked about the need for low
latency t4 inference as low as a
millisecond right for real-time lands
even low batches we've talked about the
eight regions where chief words are
available and we and the second thing or
the third thing is our network so now if
you're a social media company or you
have a worldwide group or you have users
in a certain area you really want low
latency but to get low latency it's not
just the hardware you need global
distribution of sites and it's not just
that you also need a world-class network
that's meant to that's built to give
Google search right to your mobile phone
or to your browser really quickly so
altogether that's a great ml inference
system but it's not just just the
hardware it's not just the performance
it's also about the software so tensor
RT is this piece of software from Nvidia
that optimizes inference on GPUs and
some of their new inference server
software there's some really great
innovation as well the thing I really
want to call out here have all these
things the concurrent models what that
means is you can run multiple models at
the same time in doing inference write
an aggregated way to really use the
memory and processing power of the GPU
the way I think of it is in essence
multi
Seifer inference there's a bunch of
other things that it comes along too so
I think let's take a look at a real
world example right there's a detailed
blog that we wrote that's not posted up
that walks through this but what it is
is let's say you want to run a
production ml and friend system right on
NVIDIA GPU doing real-time inference
serving you might have your users coming
to a cloud load balancer that cloud load
balancer will send traffic to multiple
zones those zones will have what we call
manage instance groups that are
collections of servers with
infrastructure those manage instance
groups will have one or more VMs
depending on how much load there is
we'll do automatic scaling based on
utilization of the infrastructure
we'll use T for GPUs with a deep
learning VM so when you create the VM
you pick deep learning you have all the
software you need right out of the bat
will use object storage to store a pre
trained model when the VM boots up it
just downloads the model and we'll use
stackdriver right after to see the
visualization of how much traffic is
coming in get the stats on CPU memory
and GPU utilization and do auto scaling
based on that so for all of those
benefits right snapchat chose t44
inference all right snapchat makes a lot
of money and ads are a big part of that
so they take in their monetization
algorithm from CPU they've partnered
with Google Nvidia they've optimized how
to get the best performance right as
well as the best cost savings they pick
t4 it's not just the t4 it's the fact
that we're eight regions Google clouds
network right worldwide great inference
so that was one example so let's look
more broadly about managing GPU
infrastructure what you might be able to
do so it's really
choose-your-own-adventure
I remember when I was a kid I read just
choose your own adventure books and if
you're a Netflix subscriber there's this
really cool choose-your-own-adventure
like movie people who love it or hate it
but with infrastructure and GPUs really
there's a choose-your-own-adventure game
there's three kind of basic models right
one you could say
I don't want him worried about the
infrastructure I'm a developer and I
want to use developer services or api's
right it's great in the sense of you
have an application and you want to
innovate quickly with hardware
acceleration just talk to some API then
there's managed services this is I do
have data scientists I do have HPC
researchers and scientists I do want to
worry about my domain expertise but I
want Google Cloud to worry about the
infrastructure and then there's the
green side the infrastructures of
service
these are VMs or containers just we're
giving you the infrastructure and you
might be managing your own
infrastructure with your own code the
benefit of this is maybe there's some
more cost from an operation standpoint
about dealing with that infrastructure
but you gain things like portability
control or performance optimizations you
lift and shift Hardware you could
support open source right we Google
Cloud have a lot of announcements about
openness hybrid multi cloud and by being
infrastructures of service right you
gain those and Google cloud with GPUs we
have access of all of these on the API
services we have ml services for text to
speech recognition video intelligence
translation vision all of that it's
hardware accelerated our managed
services we have cloud machine learning
engine right hey dupe as a service
things like that and of course
infrastructure as a service so it's just
a matter of what your organization wants
to do how you want to manage it and
where you see your value at is being I'm
not going to talk a little bit more
about the API services because if you're
a developer there's some other talks for
that here next let's talk a little bit
briefly about the mayor services first
is cloud machine learning engine right
it's all about your data scientist your
knowledge near you want to create models
and it's it's pick your own open source
machine learning framework and we'll do
training for you think of it as a bunch
of training jobs with results and
performance we help you optimize and get
better and better but you don't have to
worry about the infrastructure of VMs or
containers also we're launching
inference on GPUs as an alpha right so
you could do batch inference or
real-time inference workloads
I really really really like auto ml this
is great right Auto L Mel's if you're
not necessarily an organization that has
machine learning scientist expertise but
you have a bunch of data you have a
bunch of developers and you want to
create an AI model right without that
Auto ml's for you
hey dupe and spark as a service with GPU
powered infrastructure right or zinc
which is video rendering a service all
that hardware acceleration all of it
with an GPUs and those marinche services
you don't have to worry about the
infrastructure let's talk a little bit
more about the actual infrastructure
services GCE
obviously right we have GPUs API user
interface Wells g-cloud utility we have
managed instance groups which are those
module groups our compute with auto
scaling and GPU statistics for how busy
your GPUs are and you get auto scale
based on that this is a screen shot of
our user interface just showcasing the
flexibility you'll notice here there's
little sliders pick them out pick the
CPUs pick the memory on the bottom right
here which is kind of cut off
unfortunately and get to pick your own
GPU type GPU count complete flexibility
is available on containers or VMs let's
dive into the managed interest groups a
little bit manage interest groups are
great tools on our VM infrastructure for
batch workloads or for real-time
production workloads so if you're doing
training or an HPC run really typically
you'll have a bunch of infrastructure
you'll have a job and you want to run it
so manage in some groups are a logical
set of infrastructure if you're doing
production workloads we have things like
auto healing or multi zone groups where
you could spread your capacity across
multiple zones of Google Cloud we have
features with auto scaling where if you
want to scale based on CPU utilization
the number of jobs on your cluster that
will work out or if you don't want auto
scaling if you want to instantly create
a group who are on a job and turn it
down that works too and it creates that
repeatability process where you don't
have to worry about a fleet of VMs you
just think about the group we also have
feature
like auto-updating if you want to roll
out a new version of your HPC library or
m/l library and it also has right sizing
where if will make recommendations
saying oh by the way right we have this
custom VM shapes with custom CPU and
memory and we noticed that we cost your
GPU offloading you're not using half of
your CPUs so why don't you just don't
save a bunch of money so management
groups are great for large
infrastructure if you're not dealing
with vm's you're in containers
kubernetes engine has first-class
integration with GPUs you just run and
create a cluster you can create a
cluster of some infrastructure with out
GPU some with GPUs and then you just go
you get yourself a container right that
has whatever code you want to use the
GPU and just get running nvidia has a
the Nvidia cloud software that has
prepackaged containers including HPC our
workloads there's a bunch of open source
ones and just bring it up kubernetes
engine has auto scaling support and GPU
stats again so now as a infrastructure
service provider or an ml researcher you
don't have to worry about this fleet of
capacity you just keep running new jobs
and that the cluster grow and shrink as
you need to automatically saving you
money and saving you money is important
because of access to compute the more
money saved the more research you can do
the more innovation could happen so one
of the benefits of infrastructures
service is the portability piece right
so Google has invested a lot at open
source tensorflow
kubernetes and the coop flow is the
combination of that for ml services coop
flow is the notion of you could run
kubernetes you could run in essence an
ml system and job management and
framework tool on top or kubernetes you
could run an on-prem you could run it in
the cloud and you could be multi cloud
so let's look at HPC customer story on
using t4s and kubernetes so Sebastian at
Princeton University you know I
definitely recommend googling his name
he has some TED Talks of the research
he's doing
and he's picked Google Cloud and the t4
because of the ability for
low-cost compute to do innovative work
and he's doing brain science he's
mapping out the brain in amazing detail
and it was really fun to see him pick up
and start up thousands of T fours built
on kubernetes again with that auto
scaling and Tanner eyes workload pans
great to see the innovation just because
of the access for compute and at all is
thanks to you for playing video games in
the beginning you made this happen
thanks large cluster stuff so that HPC
workload or slumbers days large clusters
compute or opening eyes it's not just
about a single VM with with some CPU and
networking it's really about how the
cluster works and when if you have
clusters on GC P or even hybrid you're
gonna have bottlenecks and those
bottlenecks gonna have to be dealt with
what's the network performance what's in
Everglade in C right how much GPU power
you have and because of the notion the
fact that we have these custom VM shapes
and the five different GPUs you really
have unique flexibility to determine
where the bottleneck is and just switch
and swap things if your GPU constrained
right adopt the V 100 if your network or
CPU constrained go with the lower GPU it
types of performance and cost and
increase their level of CPUs also
networking is really really important
with large clusters and we're happy to
announce that all VMs GPU our CPU today
now get 32 gigabits of network
performance and we have a private alpha
where we're giving a hundred gigabits of
network performance on larger VM shapes
this really helps for both ml and HPC
workloads so that's a broad overview of
some use cases let's talk a little bit
more about access right on demand access
to GPUs which means if you are a
researcher if you have an engineer if
your organization wants get started
immediately get going right away per
second billing right you don't have to
worry about long term commits or
spending millions of dollars on a data
center and worry about if you're gonna
use it for a long time or not you don't
have to sign a contract to save money if
you just have a bunch
GPU you've infrastructure use it for a
while give it automatic 30 percent
discounts or up to and if you're not a
GCP cloud user today $300 free credit if
you're just a person right who's doing
your own study like that $300 is crate
right you could do pick up one GPU do
some learning on it do a college course
right access to this compute power is
going to enable you to succeed so we
have something called preemptable GPUs
this is a win win we have Google might
have some spare GPUs and in exchange for
you using our spare GPUs we'd give you a
70% discount and this is really great
for batch workloads or research
workloads where you want to do a bunch
more innovation on compute with the same
budget right and Stanford University is
an example of a customer who really
likes this model they don't have to
worry about flexible bidding systems
it's just always a low cost low price
today we have two more announcements
that we're making first Cu DS or
committed uses discount for GPUs if you
do like the model where you're buying
capacity from one-year or three-year
will give you up to a 50% discount this
really just as a win-win for a workload
where if you know you have to use it for
a long time one thing that is a
challenge with GPUs is access and having
capacity right it's a little known fact
that sometimes GPUs are used for Bitcoin
mining right or large workload and
because of the spiky nature of this
stuff sometimes right clouds or have
access issues and are we able to give
you access to those GPUs we want to give
everyone access to everything but that
we launched something called the
reservations where you don't need to
sign the commits you can if you want to
but if you just want to have a D risk
yourself and make sure you have access
to capacity we've now launched that for
GPUs as well as other infrastructure as
well so I'll give you a couple of tips
as the p.m. right there's a lot of large
customers small customers meeting
customers that are using GPUs and I
really really want to make sure that you
are getting the fullest extent of what
you can
so first one is all the different
product types find the one that works
for you right if you have a production
serving workload and you know you're
going to scale right use those committed
use discounts but if you have a batch
workload and you have okay if you're
okay at not getting run right way right
away use those pre-emptive VMs and mix
and match those and second make sure you
run in multiple zones so if you do that
if you only in one zone you have to
sometimes you might hit capacity issues
maybe there's a stock out maybe you
can't get something right or maybe we
have a outage in a zone but if your
software stack is able to run you to
batch production workloads in multiple
zones or multiple regions you're just
gonna save yourself right you de-risk
yourself and make sure things aren't
causing problems so one of the last
things I'll talk about is Baker Hughes
bhg GE so they're a great example of
that company who wants to innovate once
you use hardware acceleration GPUs to do
that innovation but also cares a lot
about portability until you've adopted
coop flow it's an open source machine
learning frameworks or end-to-end tool
chain system with pipelines right there
on GCE right there setting up there that
infrastructure stacked to be a way to
provide innervation to their mo
researchers and data scientists but they
love the fact that it's a no risk right
at any point of time if Google cloud
they don't want for some reason anymore
they can move to somewhere else or they
have on-site data centers to where they
might move traffic in and out and by
adopting this software tool set are
they're really able to do that so I'm
wrapping up my talk right to summarize
we announced the T 4 GPUs our fifth GPU
it's now GA scalable in eight regions
right lots of adoption for HP c ml
inference and roll training that price
performance and the flexibility
precision really really is needed if
you're picking either the V 100 or T 4
GPU and you're not looking at that
precision type for training or HPC right
you're really just throwing away money
so please look at that we announced
reservations for de-risking
the capacity as well as new ways to save
money with cuds and up to a hundred
gigabytes worth of networking right for
HPC and ml training clusters if you want
to learn more go to our website if
you're not a GCP customer you can get
$300 in credit and we have a bunch of
technical guides like the inference step
by step walkthrough or a documentation
right that you can get started and go
over
[Music]